what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation thank you so much for clicking on this
video we're gonna watch the menu for the first
time today John how are you I am hungry for
some Cinema G how are you I'm good I'm good
you know what's on the menu today like buttons
leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
also full length Reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy of the menu
available for our super sexy rejects over
at our patreon page over there we cover several
shows exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included I've heard only
good things about this movie and nothing specific
I think I saw a trailer for This months ago
in the theaters can't tell you what I what
I remember from it Ray fines is in it it's
all it's about on them let's get to it guys
[Music] hey please don't smoke it'll kill
your palate tonight is huge okay the flavor
profiles it's all super delicate when you
smoke you ruin your ability to be able to
appreciate it please aren't I get where he's
getting them coming from actually gonna love
this
we are right after the races
just a good credit for civil war okay well
it's official tonight will be Madness
you're not geeking out enough please make
yourselves comfortable for our short journey
to Hawthorne Island thank you and I've asked
me hard Jesus hope she see where the a yes
both both jokes oh yeah we're on a boat we're
on a boat
Chef slow would like to welcome you with a
raw local oyster enemy on that Emulsion it's
one of his classics lemon pearls are made
with alginate alginate is in um as an algae
come on you seem insufferable Nicholas Holt
I relate to this guy it's the balance of the
products you need the mouth feel of the minionette
please don't say a mouthful too late mouth
feel mouthful mouthful moist moist moist [Music]
welcome to Hawthorne Mr Ledford and Miss Westervelt
sorry yeah no that was uh it's not miss what
the change of plans ouch this is Miss I'm
Marco oh [Music] awkward gonna handle it differently
man yeah a million different ways what are
you working on now oh hey thanks for asking
see people still know me
are you gonna wish the paparazzi was here
each day starts at six with five hours of
prep work we Harvest we ferment we Slaughter
we marinate we liquefy we spherify we jump
we gel listen up Marco uh who lives there
Chef can we see that even we are not allowed
inside Chef's Cottage oh but we will go there
surprised by how immediate this movie is Miss
Mills Miss Mills you will be sitting in this
I'm Never Gonna Let You live that down
oh God this is awkward please do not photograph
our dishes Chef strongly feels that the beauty
in his Creations lies in their ephemeral nature
in the mouth feels do you make that with a
paco jet exactly right sir yes you know a
paco jet can produce a powderized snow-like
texture cool
there he is
such a realistic way to introduce him
is he looking at me no he's looking at not
miss Westervelt I have to change the whole
menu here we have a compressed and pickled
cucumber melon milk snow and chard lace
thank you Food Network
can you taste a little goat it's right at
the end a little kid she said no first I would
like to say thank you for the last two years
this opportunity oh dude at least we're at
work the working money yeah baby we're pathetic
aren't we yeah money work Alphas the grind
so what is it with this food thing I don't
know it's like you know how people idolize
you know athletes and musicians and Painters
and stuff those people are idiots watched
him explain the exact moment the green strawberry
is perfectly on ripe I've watched him played
a raw scallop during its last dying contraction
in oscillates art on the edge of the Abyss
which is where God works too it's the same
that was beautifully put time it was wonderfully
put I'm being serious I think I'm starting
to get it really really a little I love very
little serve human flesh nothing seems like
it's off the table
[Music]
yes I just don't think I could eat comfortably
at a place like this it's not about Comfort
it's about art and life and death and sacrifice
good evening good evening I am Julian slowik
and tonight it'll be our pleasure to feed
you hey hey I have to beg of you one thing
it's just one do not eat
Savor relish consider every morsel that you
place inside your mouth be mindful but do
not eat our menu is too precious for them
too much mouth feel they must know more about
everybody than they let on I care more about
quantity and eating until my stomach tells
me you've had enough what happens inside this
room is meaningless compared to what happens
outside in nature in the soil and the water
like balls enjoy
that [Applause] I thought he is crying I find
it all very moving it's also beautiful I just
it's almost too beautiful to eat stop taking
photos I'm really feeling this is quite it's
half great it's there in moments they're in
moments
flavors are there it's very clean it's very
um thalassic elastic Oceanic thalasso was
the Primeval spiritos yes yes so yeah you
dumbass yeah you idiot you like this the otter
fruit yeah it's salad I mean I've had shelf
is just as good with my chef at home Ricardo
you know Ricardo is amazing okay oh my God
you guys are all getting Targets on your back
what is her deal Fred has existed in some
form for over 12 000 years peasants dip their
stale measly Bread and Wine for breakfast
Jesus teach us to pray if not to beg for our
daily bread overachiever
but you my dear guests are not the Common
Man and so tonight you get no bread what I
love bread yeah what what gives half the reason
I go to Cheesecake Factory is for the bread
bottomless no bread this Emulsion does look
slightly split oh golly I mean I was gonna
say cut his head off yep serve them as the
next course in the restaurant of this quality
There It Is Well there it is yeah oh my God
I mean it's next level badasser
he's not just a chef he's a he's a Storyteller
and he doesn't give a [__] about the rules
only the girl next door but maybe there are
some rules that you should give up about like
I don't know giving food to people at a restaurant
there is no one would ever call you the Girl
Next Door Nicholas Holtz has now morphed into
my favorite character well I can just love
his positive attitude about it all
[Music] singled out you talk a little loud
um I mean look the food's great and we totally
get all the conceptual stuff but could we
please get a little bread you know and some
gluten-free for my friend as well no yikes
I know who you are influencer you know we
work with Doug Barrick right flip is a little
bread please we won't tell a soul lady
yeah I promise okay no foreign
[Music] [Laughter] star pupil you haven't
touched your food there is no food yes do
I want to fill up that would not be possible
I've precisely designed the portions to account
for that so you won't fill up the menu only
makes sense if you eat but you told us not
to eat that is not what I meant Madam you
know it yeah well thank you for your concern
but I am perfectly capable of deciding when
I eat and what you're embarrassing him Mario
in front of the patriarchy all right that
was humiliating humiliating yeah Tyler the
guy's a prick oh too loud this whole situation
is just awkward yep
next course is called memory and that is what
is meant to evoke so let me tell you a memory
of mine when I was growing up a child in Waterloo
Iowa Tuesday was taco night oh yeah Taco Tuesday
this is my mother hey when I was seven years
old one Tuesday my father came home quite
drunk my mother grew angry and screamed at
him at which point he proceeded to wrap a
telephone cord around her neck and pull it
tight what is this story he's gonna serve
the telephone cord well I finally had to stab
him in the thigh with kitchen scissors wow
this is a Macabre meal I hope everyone gets
to remember some traumatic memories right
now how smoked breast chicken thigh al pastor
and our own tortillas made with heirloom mask
the images on the tortillas have been made
using a laser engraving machine it's the first
time we've used it oh no oh no they like personal
memories printed on the tortillas that sounds
like it they're restaurants that I reviewed
that all closed like a gag it's like Chef
jigsaw it's a very emotional dinner it's very
personalized me oh that's why Margo's throwing
the whole thing off um Tyler is that you they're
on me from tonight taking photos
Dr Sunshine dumb part bad script one shoot
though right um
whoa what the hell are these These are tortillas
these are tortillas which contain echobright's
tax records and other documents showing how
your company has created invoices with fake
charges
whoa who is that woman uh oh damn it I was
hoping it wouldn't be it's faint it's some
sort of sort of stupid joke Taco okay can't
hurt you yeah and taco that might hold up
in court so eat the evidence hey I have to
make this right somehow I have to well I'll
tell you how you make it right you send this
[__] back excuse me excuse me sir hi oh
he snapped oh I don't snap no and I don't
really care send [__] back to this kitchen
oh child this is incredible you have to try
this no thanks thanks don't let me interrupt
damn that was cold dude oh boy
cigarette is ruining the taste you're barely
eating the food why why do you care I take
my work very seriously and you're not eating
and that wounds me if you put the cigarette
out and move out of nose nah blow smoke in
his face who are you I am Marco you shouldn't
be here tonight please get the [__] out
of my way yikes are you trying to save you
it's like the one audience member in your
stand-up crowd who's not laughing yeah Jeremy
created the next dish it's called the mess
he's good he's very good enough but he's not
great God do you like this life this life
that you've dreamed about no chef and do you
want my life Wow no sure well it's just another
day for Greg and John Yep this is how we start
out John do you want my life
Jeremy's the mess please wow
oh damn I did not see that coming wow I didn't
see that coming
um
what is that this is an exclusive experience
please
thank you so much and now they're gonna wrap
them up and roast him in that they're gonna
put him in a giant smoker or something
this is what he does it's part of the menu
enjoy your femur bone questioning what's in
that huh
you cheer me I want a refund there is no boat
to leave on then I'll call a helicopter that
would be very difficult without phone service
just with which hand will you handle this
left or right oh no oh crazy I'm gonna cut
off your hand choose what very well left hand
ring finger oh my God
please hold still
straight to the point
please [__]
Jesus Christ it's all part of the menu okay
I honestly think that this whole thing is
just for our benefit I mean oh that's why
he texted me ugh Chef slowly would like to
see you in the kitchen can I come too absolutely
not sir
can I come too this menu this guest list this
entire evening has been painstakingly planned
and you are not a part of that plan and it's
spoiling everything is it now proceed I have
to know where to seat you with us or with
them oh and then you'll let me live that you
live no we're all going to die tonight
do you want to die with those who give or
with those who take please pick die a giver
in 15 minutes I'll take a break between courses
and that is how long you have to decide I
give her I mean you wouldn't know how to cook
though oh my God what if Nicholas holds like
yeah I know we're gonna die yeah that's why
it's the whole reason I signed up unfair why
do you get a kitchen of course smoke all day
can't even taste it oh
we have better knife skills than that what
other choice do we have um oh boy no you're
not
I mean I would first try to take out the guards
and stuff right please let me without you
[Laughter] don't worry you can always go back
to your Comedy Central show any questions
Bergamot I'm getting a chef yes it is
beautiful
we we want to know what the [__] is this
happening man well I'll tell you think of
yourselves as ingredients in the degu station
concept Miss Bloom knows the damage she has
done to so many livelihoods no no no no hang
on no no no no you don't talk how many times
have you eaten here in the last five years
11 times Mr librand kindly name one dish you
ate the last time you were here oh my God
tell me one dish you ate the last time you
were here for the time before not bread Cod
it wasn't caught you donkey I've allowed my
work to reach the price point where only the
class of people in this room can access and
I've been fooled in trying to satisfy people
who could never be satisfied that that's our
culture isn't it and my restaurant is part
of the problem uh I would have to say that
Doug Varick owns me except now things a little
more complicated and I own Doug Varick [Music]
what's going on oh my when he questioned my
menu you would even request substitutions
despite the fact that there are no substitution
the whole fallen angel please oh [Music] [Applause]
[Music] that's cool do you hear
do you hear it do you hear that silence listen
can you hear it and standing on every word
we thought I couldn't tell oh I know a fellow
service industry worker when I see one Mr
librand how do you know him you've been eyeing
him all evening oh I think you know oh no
what rattled me is that he told me to tell
him that he was a good man and that I was
his daughter and that he left me and I loved
him he's a romantic yeah that's what I would
put oh do you enjoy providing your services
do you enjoy providing yours I haven't desired
to cook for someone in ages and one does miss
that feeling oh they're connecting cook for
Margot the next course let us take the evening
air come on outside we should create some
type of immersive experience out of this yeah
that wouldn't go wrong in any way shape or
form don't be frightened nothing to be frightened
of so maybe there's a spirit building somewhere
we can get out of here what red dead it's
okay no we're gonna die tonight yeah such
a Yes Man
Julian sloark tried to fight me I refused
he kept me in his kitchen and refused to look
me in the eye speak directly to me for eight
months cold our next course is called man's
folly
we will be serving sausage and eggs God
I mean he's like what to our male diners we
now offer you the chance to escape you'll
be given a 45 second head start at which point
members of my staff will try and catch you
if they do catch laughs holy [__] what
hold this
I'll send for help first thing not such a
beast after all Nicholas Holt I have no clue
where this is going nope even Chef is not
morally Superior go
it is the most dangerous game
this is fantastic the tartness of the umaboshi
and the the waves of ferment it's it's rich
and yet it's clean it's delicious
[Music] better it's so good it's really good
Jesus
let's go
you know my husband
foreign
it doesn't work if you live what doesn't work
the menu I mean really you should have your
own place right and I could help you with
that clever oh everyone dying with my pitch
actually
oh God anybody want anyone yes thank you
[Music]
definitely keep your voices down foreign
special bite for the last guest to be caught
of course what did you do out there I'm the
only one who got away I'm sorry I'm a failure
it's okay I've been stealing money for me
oh wow yeah I know I'm afraid I'm in you cannot
continue as planned until we deal with an
unresolved matter it's got bread tell me why
you're here I wanted to experience your food
chef what were you told ahead of time be the
greatest menu ever created right and and that
everyone would die oh my God you asked what
yes you brought manga that's just because
you don't offer ceilings for one so you hired
her knowing she'd die wow yes yes ma'am
you're a cook Cooks belong in the kitchen
come with me psychopath
nope Tyler now cook I don't cook look Tyler
Jesus man damn it man Charlotte for the great
foodie the phenomenal Mr Food himself everyone
gather around they must learn from Tyler this
is a new uh a new dice oh poor guy as much
as I hate you poor guy I bear witness to a
revolution in Cuisine protein
no you're missing all the basics gradual man
you're gonna like burn himself or something
let's be like son of Rich parents or some
[__] huh it's actually quite bad [__]
[Music]
you are why the mystery has been drained from
our art
[Music]
go climb in the oven Tyler dessert requires
a large barrel that is supposed to be there
in the corner Margo you will fetch the barrel
instead give her the SmokeHouse key
Elsa Elsa Elsa you had one job I just don't
think it's really fair you want to know why
you're being punished I saw the film calling
Dr sunshine I did not enjoy it I didn't direct
it I just acted in it the memory of your face
in that film
and what about her what school did you go
to Brown student loans
I'm sorry you're dying wow
[Music]
that's cool it's like a replica no one is
allowed inside Chef's house do you think you're
special oh usually there's a knife there trust
me I have no idea
you have all kinds of items there yep get
a pan
[Music]
coaching he didn't tell me talk about the
barrel I didn't forget
oh geez [Music] you have a chance to survive
come on Aaron yeah yep yep [Music]
nope
[Music]
hello happy birthday oh geez you told them
it was my birthday seemed funny about three
hours ago thank you
as Dr King said we know through painful experience
that freedom is never voluntarily given by
the oppressor it must be demanded by the oppressed
he just caught Martin Luther King sure did
[Laughter]
clear the dining room immediately oh why would
you return they planned for this ask yourselves
two things one if you really want to be responsible
for the death of an innocent man and two ask
yourselves this entire evening why didn't
you all try harder to fight back huh I could
have fought all them did anybody here call
in a distress over the shortwave tonight
notice the injured guy uh are you
I'm a big fan thank you would you like this
autograph I don't want to bother you oh no
no no help me just don't say you love that
movie that the chef hates my wife and I we
love that oh what's it called the one where
you play the surgeon yeah calling Dr Sunshine
yeah thank you so much go react to the note
oh thank you for your service
hands on your head everyone
my God what's coming from behind the window
on your knees with your hands over your head
now
yeah now no
damn it
no
thank you death thank you
oh God he's [__] me so I'm in the kitchen
we all work together and nothing works at
all [Laughter] you've betrayed our sacred
Bond of trust shown your craft to be careless
oh my God cut his throat final course plating
in five
you can take some of them right if they like
really band together use some of the objects
around you [Music] I don't like your food
and I would like to send it back every dish
you served tonight has been some intellectual
exercise rather than something you want to
sit and enjoy true true it tastes like it
was made with no love oh this is ridiculous
we always cook with love don't we laughs I
thought tonight was a night of hard home truth
this is one of them you cook with Obsession
not love
your single purpose on this Earth is to serve
people food that they might actually like
and you have failed you failed and you've
bored me the worst part is I'm still hungry
you know what I'd really like tell me Burger
a cheeseburger not me no we can do a cheeseburger
laughs how do you like it medium American
cheese because it melts without splitting
how much will that set me back 9.95 [Music]
a crinkle cut Julian curly fries everything
oh my God is it's gonna bring him back to
the love Yeah making it himself come on Carmi
cook with passion
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the most lovely cooking sequins too
[Music] how happy he looks
not a roughly plate and all [Music] damn them
fries look good [Music] I would have asked
for that onions I'll take your onions boy
give me all the onions
no that is a cheeseburger unfortunately I
think my eyes were a little bigger than my
stomach don't push it can I get the rest to
go [Music] clever girl one moment please [Music]
one cheeseburger to go thank you for dining
at Hawthorne oh my God thank you for um for
a couple bucks you played well
um oh boy you still can so once again thank
you for dining with us tonight you represent
the ruin of my art oh now you get to be a
part of it part of what I hope is my masterpiece
are they gonna burn the place down I hope
so let's go yes just go ahead and roll around
in those coat yourself
foreign
[Music] 's a s'more [Music] as made of chocolate
you must embrace the flame
[Music] yeah cast iron hands like Mars or
Heretics we can be subsumed Anew thank you
I love you all I even they're saying it oh
no
damn oh
don't go no it's gonna blow up yeah it's gonna
be filled with graham crackers and marshmallows
customers staff at restaurant that's great
laughs
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
well done oh she got away Adam McCain wolf
Ferrell's company produces huh bam sure I
told them okay that was a movie that was oof
that was a satire if ever there was the lower
class wins people yeah man lower class wins
they come out on top who needs old-fashioned
cheeseburger sex worker gets to come out on
top of some talking about baby right yeah
all you filthy rich disgusting Pricks that
was your fake high class sensibility yeah
you'll go down in flames you know or a bunch
of petty [__] and the irony of s'mores
Poor People's food yeah that's what they call
it you should be so lucky is to let the poor
Eat You Alive that was uh that was delicious
no pun intended all that food looked not appetizing
not gonna lie and did not want to eat any
of them a couple I had no no flavor for it
I was like I would never eat this I don't
know I like quantity poor mans you want yeah
you want quantity of food I want to I want
something cheap and a bunch of crap cheeseburgers
flavor [__] Munch and then and his weight
takes like 20 30 minutes for your stomach
to tell you're full and then just keep eating
until that signal comes in and you eat till
you like hate life that's the way to do it
if you're gonna pay that much money for food
all right that's that's what I'm getting at
with this yeah 12.50 ahead or whatever I was
surprised by how uh quick and immediate it
was uh just normally with these horror films
it's like there's kind of it was funnier than
I expected it to be I mean I didn't know what
the genre of filming was but I would classify
this as like a horror dark horror comedy I
I feel like it's in really it's it's intentionally
funny it's like a lot of black comedy yeah
yeah it was funny it was a really funny film
absolutely and I was surprised by how funny
it was uh I I thought it would be because
you know that's reminding you of like a lot
of the like you were trying to name off oh
yeah ready or not earlier all right yeah yeah
ready or not you want to call it hide and
seek but yeah ready or not no radio silence
hide and seek Robert De Niro it's uh Ready
or Not uh there are flavors of all those kind
of things I thought I was gonna go down to
your next route it was not a your next route
oh yeah some kind of like bloody all-out like
survival thing yeah yeah I think Ready or
Not is probably the more apt title descriptor
for it and then of course you got films very
recent like don't worry darling to a certain
extent really uncomfortable dinner scene that
take place uh in this offshoot Island there's
oh I think there's a bunch of movies you can
name yeah that yeah this is a type of movie
but it's a good cat and mouse type of game
with Ray fines and Anya Taylor Joy uh that
I really enjoyed I thought it was really fun
I like its political social commentary a classism
uh and it it didn't feel like overtly I mean
I would say it's pretty overt it didn't feel
overly bogged down by it it seemed like the
game was the front and center of the show
it didn't get lost in the commentary especially
because Rey finds a chef is is [__] insane
he's he's nutso so I'm never like listening
to him going man's got a point he's got a
good point you know yeah even even in times
where it threatens to push you out into that
direction the movie does bring him down to
either pettiness or some other self-serving
and like I like the way that Ray finds really
strikes the balance of like this is truly
a guy who believes that he is humbling himself
and giving up his ego and yeah and making
this Grand example and yet there is still
this sort of shriveled Petty guy at the center
of that and I like that this movie because
he's lording he's the puppet master of this
whole show this whole charade I like that
the movie doesn't actually try to maintain
that he is some kind of moral Authority in
this little bubble like it humanizes him too
and I think that that helps I think it drastically
helps otherwise it would have felt like the
movie's preaching it to me as if he's some
type of social justice story yeah yeah some
kind of Jigsaw type guy he was like he's doing
it the wrong way but he's got the right ideas
you know like yeah I mean I I think they managed
to make with this Chef character Chef slowik
uh they they managed to make the movie surprisingly
character driven even when you're not in his
perspective this whole thing is sort of from
his perspective because you see that he comes
from a troubled past sounds like he came from
a poor past and then as he rose through the
ranks and rooster ladder like he talks about
how his business flourished or it now only
caters to the definition of like the 0.5 percent
out there and what has become of his art and
what has become of him and and everything
he's talking about is the deterioration of
of him and the reflection of that through
the customers that he has so it's not some
type of to me I didn't read it as preachy
even though the film clearly has that imbued
in there it doesn't feel like I'm being talked
at because it's all sounding like this is
all from the character of the chef and this
is the world point of view that we have all
gotten suckered into because of him and so
it makes sense why someone like Margot who
or Aaron whatever her name is you know seeing
a I thought that was clever seeing the photo
of what he was you know once a really happy
guy who did it out of love and with the burgers
yeah yeah that was clever and then to order
for the burger remind him of the love for
that and then asking for that to go or I'm
like oh you brought back a nostalgic memory
rod and it got you out of here you clever
clever ass poor girl you found a way to win
the unwinnable game yeah yeah it was it was
smart it was it was really smart and I love
the the cult-like manipulation of uh like
it's the the restaurant represents uh a sort
of mindset of society and I really like that
a lot yeah no I'm surprised by this movie
it was funnier and faster than I expected
some people I feel like my categorize has
a slow burn but I don't think it was slow
it was more like I don't know where it's going
but you know and once you get to the like
the guy who um uh trying to watch my words
here there's this the shoe Chef the suit the
sushi sous chef and then they're like okay
this is interesting yeah but I was I was into
it of of like I like the horror movies like
I don't know what's happening here you know
but I'm really into the fact that I could
tell something bad's gonna go down like like
movies like the invitation and [__] like
that where again isolated location and you
know like murders around the corner you know
yeah yeah absolutely I thought this did nicely
I think you yeah like it's not overtly a cult
thing but it is and I think that's part of
the the fun of the genre and the commentary
is the cult that forms around the chef both
in the kitchen and outside of the kitchen
and the cult that can grow around like you
know people who just have opinions and authorities
and are you know given platform enough to
put them out there at will and you know pull
the strings of other people's lives like I
liked I liked what this made of itself and
I like the deliberate quality of it because
I mean yeah it is I almost like that we don't
have to open on some kind of like preliminary
prologue sequence or something like that it
throws you in and it doesn't necessarily like
obviously Margot is the cipher but she's not
even like a hundred percent us which I appreciate
because funny enough throughout this I I was
often reminded of hide and seek and I think
what I liked murderer ready or not someday
I like I like that movie and I heard a lot
of people being like Oh man like it's so sharp
with the class commented but that was the
movie that felt like it was kind of putting
it in my face whereas this I I appreciated
that it kind of just plops a bunch of characters
together and it gives you this structure and
a power set but also it kind of just lets
you look at and draw your conclusions about
anyone and everyone and I love that certain
things are the morality play like the husband
and wife and like oh he's been seeing it just
so happens that the same prostitute he hired
is here um but then you have stuff like genre
guzama where it's just like I went to your
movie on my one day off and I freaking hated
it and too often well it was beyond that it
was the it was the fact that your passion
is gone yeah yeah it was yeah it was like
watching one of those actors yeah and and
but even that like I I appreciate that even
within that there is a certain level of there
there is a philosophy to it but it is like
a pettier thing on the hierarchy of concerns
that are happening in this room and I thought
it added a lot of it just added a lot of like
human color that made all the characters feel
very human even though the situation is so
heightened and I thought that the way they
stylized the characters was good because everyone's
pretty distinct and there are certainly very
dark comedic choices but no one's playing
too much of a big character like even Nicholas
Holt who is like kind of the biggest joke
the whole time because like far past the point
and it's it's Justified because he knows technically
about the deaths although even in that scene
I'm like does he know that it really means
they're gonna die like how much seriousness
was stressed to this guy but even with him
even the way that he is constantly just eating
up this guy's words far past the point where
everyone else is like this is messed up you
know I get spoiled rich kid who never had
to work for anything um from him sure like
that's like the whole vibe yeah and an armchair
expert who's never actually done the thing
for real and never actually cared to you know
put their not that you have to become a master
of anything and everything you talk about
but at the same time it seems like to Grant
the true appreciation you would have to try
well yeah and I think it's part of the commentary
of the film is people feeling like they're
never gonna be good enough no matter what
Heights they achieve and I think the kitchen
setting you know with Ray finds sort of being
the image that you know kind of associated
with like a Gordon Ramsay where it is like
a it feels like a whatever you see anything
like that it feels like a church yeah like
he is Lord and everything else everyone it's
like prostrate before him yeah that's what
I hear of like what it's like being in a ballet
school you know everything is it feels like
a religion in a way and and it's a constant
fear of discipline and of being disciplined
and not rising to be good enough and so I
think using like the setting of that representing
a lot of what's wrong with Society and reflecting
it with the separation of the rich it's pretty
cool yeah there's a lot of cool things about
it it was and it's tight setting of a good
acting throughout man I thought Nicholas Holt
was a blast he was so fun I thought John link
was almost really good too he was great I
thought he was excellent yeah no I mean John
like he's he's the best because he'll show
up in every kind of movie but he's always
really committed well I like that he you know
presents himself like he's the [__] but
then he just slowly peels back that he's the
furthest thing from being the [__] yeah
he's just shitty you know yeah totally and
I thought that was great um but I liked seeing
Arturo Castro get such a kind of focal side
character because I've been a fan of him since
seeing his Comedy Central show I never would
have expected to see him in a place like this
and I think he's comedy director sure yeah
yeah and I mean like there there is I mean
John Leguizamo has a good amount of comedy
in his background too and you said Hong Chow
is is funny yes um but yeah like I I I was
just kind of Charmed and pleasantly surprised
by like oh yeah like I buy this guy like as
well cast his his comedic chops are well placed
here um but yeah like they cast across the
board even even the actors whose faces I know
and don't really like the critic and the magazine
guy like everybody was really distinct for
the most part even if you don't really get
to know many of them beyond the types that
they are and uh you know just let the the
construction of the menu was really well done
and the way they intercut these like food
something higher grade than Food Network but
you know like the the actual like oh it kind
of looks like a cooking show now where you're
doing an insert on the dish and it's explaining
what it is like it had just enough flourish
but without feeling like too much of a fun
house or like you know like we're having too
much like the style and the presentation of
the movie is very restrained as to match the
menu itself yeah I felt like some parts in
the the first like half hour with its editing
was a little off to me and my play differently
on a on a second viewing but I thought this
first go around it was a little it was a little
there were times where I was like I could
do with a tad different pacing because I'm
I'm just kind of keeping up with the amount
of cutting we're doing versus sinking into
the mood of it and there's a but it eventually
got me I was like pretty much eyes glued to
the screen for the whole time I was really
into it but that's like a really small thing
here I didn't like I really enjoyed everyone
and I I wasn't I wouldn't be be honest I wouldn't
be bummed if any like I wasn't bummed at the
fact of all them dying yeah like like none
of it I was when they said they're gonna die
I'm like oh good I hope they all die I hope
the movie goes there I hope the movie lets
them die and I like they didn't go down a
generic route of Anya Taylor Joy figuring
out how to get everyone out of here yeah yeah
yeah I thought that's where they might go
yeah there's a big distinction that that looms
between her and everybody else yeah yeah and
I just what I found really unique was the
was the interpretation the execution of the
chef character because this is all again any
other movie I feel like wouldn't have made
it so character based and why he's doing what
he's doing but there is something that is
so despairing about his portrayal and self-pitying
at the same time you know and I I love that
everything we're watching is because of this
man's uh failure to enjoy success sure yeah
and to remain connected to his passions and
his goals and why yeah yeah yeah it's like
it's all he's lost sight of so much and they
do touch on like almost everything you know
with uh the idea of servitude they comment
a little bit on the metoo movement as well
yeah sexual harassment um you know uh that
you know I saw Will Ferrell and Adam McKay
produced it I was like oh the whole thing
with like corporate greed scheming and yeah
faked uh yeah the the tortilla faked uh transaction
records and stuff like that yeah I think that
they could have definitely gone down a more
cliche path with every character but they
didn't you know even the three Bros I I thought
we were like okay here we go they were about
to the movie hates these guys are especially
with three alpha males but the the actors
they chose they I thought brought a lot of
like surprise it was in the scene with Hong
Chao is refusing to give them bread which
is a choice by the way that I loved yeah I
loved that they didn't give them bread because
it's beyond the fact that it's such a common
Association you know like with a restaurant
like hey you get bread it's just that's just
what you get but you know pulling it back
with how this is what poor people survived
off of and you're you're supposed to be better
than that right yeah yeah but the fact that
they still clamor for it when they have all
these rich Delights that they entitled to
it yeah as much as they want as much as they
need it they're still they lose sight of like
what that bread actually kind of represents
yeah you know but there's also something to
be said with like they don't really talk about
it but I feel like a lot of restaurants are
like you get so much bread you get unlimited
bread like it's kind of a greed filled plate
of the easy thing to like give it yeah and
a lot of times it's like you know you get
full before you even get the food because
you're just stocked up on so much bread and
I love that I love that about restaurants
I hope they never change that Cheesecake Factory
Olive Garden almost every Italian restaurant
bread non-stop bread free bread it's the best
dipping in oil and vinegar I'm craving it
right now as I'm talking about it I don't
know what part of this food movie made me
go I want that but except for the fries but
bread oil and vinegar it's delicious yeah
and I think too I mean it's good music too
by the way yeah yeah really well done elegant
haunting music and I mean I like that yeah
I like the way it skewers the restaurant and
cuisine just subset of of people and the way
even like Nicholas hold at the beginning like
slags off every other kind of art as being
useless um but two I've often heard it said
that like you know any and all cooking movies
to some degree can be sort of used as a also
metaphor for filmmaking and I wonder that's
that's part of why I was wondering why the
direct how many films or what kind of films
this director had done prior because I I have
to I just have to feel like there is some
element here of the struggle when it comes
to really any kind of art form but I'm sure
Cinema because it is such a both because you
can get very hoity-toity high class about
something that is a more populist art form
in general much like the bread and so you
know I think this is nice because this has
a good array between its characters of like
little microcosms of themery like there's
the big overarching like yeah class yeah and
uh and you know commodification and all those
things but I think it's it does well in the
life of its other characters and stuff too
yeah have a tapestry that I think you could
draw multiple threads out of rather than just
one major one and uh I think that's just a
nice sort of uh earmark when you can do that
with a movie like this it's like it's good
enough I think to have you know this sort
of haves versus have-nots ideology and exploration
but to you know then give it its own twist
depending on which of each of the characters
like the mom isn't technically part of this
set she is just you know a an aspect of Chef's
Life in a cycle of abuse that she was never
able to break which is a whole other thing
you know and the fact that she's being punished
for it in this way is is an interesting one
and it's it's stuff like that that doesn't
necessarily fully go into the overall uh the
one percent is terrible um that I think you
know I like when yeah when they can kind of
imbue different stuff like that when they
take the time because they don't have it but
he but for who he is he blames her sure yeah
you know yeah and again like this is all chefs
like the menu is the chef's menu you know
it's all script it's all perfectly curated
and that greed comes in many forms I think
and even with the cup the guy who lost his
finger uh that the dude who was constantly
cheating on his wife you know it's and I like
how this movie lets you kind of Imagine a
little bit of backstory with people versus
telling you yeah like Nicholas Holtz I kind
of just filled that in that's sort of what
seems like it's in his performance of spoiled
rich kid um because this guy doesn't look
like he's [__] Hernandez and then even
with the old couple I imagine like they he
was once not super successful sure and he
probably grew in success with her and then
and it wasn't good enough so his relationship's
not good enough his wife's not good enough
so he starts seeking it elsewhere yeah you
know I I think that's I guess it was a fun
it's a fun stuff happening here it's a fun
movie yeah more fun and on Taylor Joy is great
as always she's always good even yeah I can't
think of the time I bought you was bad no
she's I've thought of things that she's been
underused yeah I can't think of times where
I'm like she's she sucks and she's great again
and uh a perfect I love how her how her character
unfolds allowing allowing the opening at the
very end poor people win a movie that was
produced by people with money I mean like
my favorite favorite thing I do often wonder
like yeah it's like how big of a budget movie
can you be like this had to cost money for
the Stars anyway and how much do you how much
do you think about that when you sign on you're
like I just read this great script about classism
now where's my million dollars yeah but but
too like I liked it on you Taylor Joy even
in being so is not made out to be like the
immaculate perfect Saint poor girl she's just
kind of like a real feeling person and she's
the most sympathetic but the movie doesn't
necessarily thrust her to you as like full-on
100 agreeable audience Cipher character I
mean even though she's like a hired escort
as well she's not played like you're a [__]
you do what I want you know well yeah and
it's like if you didn't if they didn't touch
on that in the dialogue you could not even
you you wouldn't necessarily have to even
interpret it that way yeah yeah yeah it's
just like you got unlucky and you got swapped
in probably this girl dumped this guy and
now you're here we have everything we've said
the one thing we haven't said which I'm so
surprised we haven't said is Ray finds it's
really phenomenal oh yeah like there's a guy
who's played that that guy's played so many
villains by this point and that was part of
my lack of interest in watching this was I
already finds as a villain again okay sure
uh I'm like like that's not Saving Private
Ryan for the first time reaches I'm like yeah
he's the villain and really and uh no I've
seen him Saving Private Ryan I'm just I thought
you had seen it yes what you said you saw
savior Ryan uh uh Schindler's List okay yeah
um yeah and um the and then of course Voldemort
and like the countless red dragon the list
comes on and off Ray finds as a villain and
I really love how he doesn't play it like
he's having fun with his food here he really
plays it like a tortured soul and a guy who's
like clinically lost his mind and is depressed
like he's a dude he's really depressed who's
resigned to this yeah it's very it's a very
solemn performance and uh with a smile that
feels so put on versus um ladybird versus
evil Glee what like there's he doesn't play
it evil and it was so cool to see him play
it very human like a full-on character and
to bring something refreshing to to to care
to a role that there's very many generic ways
you could have done it and and Ray finds brings
something so special here and I think after
some decades I'd say you're playing villains
he manages to bring something very unique
once again that doesn't feel repetitive or
pulled from like I've seen Ray fines do this
before because as much as he's the villain
the furthest thing he does is play it as a
villain and I think that's awesome right down
to the the greatest game uh that's another
great amount of classes of metaphor oh the
the most that's happened yeah the most dangerous
game have the rich people run yeah well and
that's uh I I appreciate too that that could
that's an aspect of these movies where yeah
like whoever's gonna figure out the game they
have some kind of eye to eye moment moment
of mutual respect and I liked the way they
drew that here because it did not at all feel
hackneyed or like we just need this to happen
because of the script like the way they played
the connection and the in like the Curiosity
between and then the ultimate not connection
but just the way that they kind of see one
another Margot and and uh and the chef I thought
was really nicely done too because that's
an aspect that could easily become cliched
or or read as you know a contrivance and I
thought they made a nice just they made nice
out of that here they made something kind
of Rich out of that here and so when it's
like he doesn't get the Redemption at the
end but it is like you you buy that last glimmer
of like you did beat me at my own game and
in the process you brought me something I
never thought I would feel again and now it
almost gives his eventual death and completion
of the menu sort of a a bit of relief yeah
yeah so it's like it's I thought they made
interesting stuff out of most every choice
like at every turn when I thought it could
rest on being just a fun there's something
often very fun about a you know dark satire
I feel like I feel like often these kinds
of movies come with a gleeful sort of energy
to watch people be poked and prodded and I
thought that this movie actually didn't give
in to that and it's not always even a bad
thing but I'm glad they didn't hear like there
is a Glee and there is a dark humor going
on behind the camera but it's so restrained
that it lets the characters all just breathe
as they are and I think that's a tremendous
asset to an experience like this one million
percent I enjoyed it yep enjoyed it four to
five I would order it again in fact and eat
it on a rock locally sourced all right guys
well what did you think about the menu do
you agree are you rich throwing your raw steak
at the menu your HBO Max subscription that's
right your ad free top tier HBO Max that you're
watching on your solid gold iPad hey let's
shout out someone from our patreon page
aniso liver Anisa I would like to cook for
you oh you know what I would make you I would
first get a toaster then I would put two slices
of bread in there oh and I'd slowly walk over
to my cabinet whilst the bread is toasting
private reserve bread pull out a jar of peanut
butter open it put my fingers in taste it
oh not wash my hands put that in my fingers
back in that peanut butter spread it on the
bread then I go back in the fridge the saliva
brings it together grab some mustard [Music]
put my whole hand in the mustard jar sweet
and Tart I'll lick my whole hand put it on
the other slice of bread then I'd fold those
pieces of bread together look at that that's
a new invention I'm out of knives so I would
tear it in half rip it now keep in mind it's
all toasty so it's just gonna like crumble
everywhere it's gonna melt on the floor it's
been really messy you're gonna eat it off
the floor then I drop it on the floor and
I say eat this [__] Anisa lap it up say
that's how we do it in Texas
good old floor Witch good old peanut butter
and mustard floor witch peanut butter mustard
sandwich from the floor from yours truly it
needs some that's what I want to do for you
in 2023 I think that's a manageable goal honestly
I'd fly to Texas just to watch you do that
um and we'll bring the bread you just bring
the people no why am I wasting my breath of
course of course if you're gonna make a trip
out for it right now your bread in fact you
can get the plane ticket too I'm not buying
the bread yeah Chef Greg doesn't stoop to
such levels I'll bring the mustard from California
I'll fly over and grind I got the seeds myself
got a half eaten bottle of mustard already
them bring it over in the plane sneak it onto
mine sneak it into your carry-on carry on
risk them taking it for being they were too
much too big I can't detect there's no ingredients
in it there's an empty mustard bun in there
for three years it's not gonna oh everything
is just you can't register it is no longer
a paste it is a solid we can heat it up when
we get there and then yeah perfect I love
you a Nissan no no I'm just kidding we'll
take you to Denny's or some [__] I'll
take you for a burger all right love you I'm
a real no she got me a great wedding presents
[Music]